i came into this movie like i'm down
whatever you guys want me to do kind of
thing was there something that you were
asked to do that you just said no
no i said yes to everything
i just trusted them
that i wasn't gonna die what was the
audition process i'm very curious do
people go in and run
head first into a wall
that's pretty good let's see the next
guy what was the audition process um the
audition process was like they just we
just i got randomly hit up by someone on
instagram
and then they like said they're a part
of some like jackass anniversary special
so it was gonna be like some documentary
thing they're gonna talk to me because
it was like
um they didn't because they wanted to
they pretty much just wanted to talk to
me because i like do similar type stuff
then i go in and meet with knox and
jermaine they still are acting like it's
that kind of a thing
then i go in again like actually it's
for the movie and they're like wanting
me to do a stunt and stuff and they
didn't then we ended up going and doing
this pre-shoot with a couple other new
people
and they were just seeing if it actually
worked like with these new people and
the original chemistry what was the
stunt um
i did uh
i did this thing i did a motorcycle jump
that i did with them wait wait wait do
you ride a motorcycle no
no
no that's why i did it
what was that one called again um that
was the
it was like human rams no the human ramp
yeah it was human ramp so what did you
do you had to get on a motorcycle yeah i
had to i get on this little motorcycle
and they stack like i think it was aaron
there's danger aaron
knox yeah yeah we man we man and like
preston or whatever up uh just on top of
each other and they put this piece of
wood on them right and then i'd drive
the motorcycle or i just jumped them how
fast were you going uh
i mean factoring in my weight to the
motorcycle i'm not sure but i was
supposed to be able to go like like 20
or 30. why do you factor your weight i
mean you're gonna go a little bit slower
like like i would go a little bit slower
than like someone else like because it
wasn't even meant for my weight capacity
like to be going like 20 miles an hour
yeah probably like 20 up a ramp yeah
upper ramp and then on the other side of
the ramp what happens um i eat [ __ ]
because i did i don't know how to land
or anything like that so you don't
practice it's not like they're
professional stunt coordinators or
anything i mean there are professional
people around but they're not like but
they don't they don't they're not part
of the production yeah they're just like
okay it'd probably be best if you try
not to kill yourself they're there for
emotional support yeah yeah emotional
support stunt coordinator yeah yeah yeah
so did you you fell yeah i fell i ended
up like hitting my shoulder really hard
and like rolling a bunch right um that
was pretty much it it was awesome though
like i was i was it it hurt really bad
after actually hurt to breathe for a
while afterwards right
for like a couple so that's the audition
yeah that was the audition that was that
was like similar to what happened for me
because like knoxville slid into my dms
and which one day i noticed knoxville
was liking a bunch of my content and i
was like why is he more supportive than
my boyfriend on instagram like why does
he like all of my stuff
and then he asked me to you know he
framed it like an anniversary special
and i met with um jeff and knoxville and
then the rest is pretty much history i
was there on the it's not history yet
what was yours what was your stunt um i
didn't have to do a stunt in the meeting
i they just asked if i wanted to be a
part of it and
um i said i didn't know what that meant
but i just said yes
so
because no means no
um
so let me ask you so you you land on the
motorcycle you can't breathe your
shoulder is [ __ ] up and as you're
lying there in the dirt trying to guess
for air are you thinking oh i hope i get
a call back yeah yeah yeah like oh i got
up instantly and was like i was like
super stoked i was actually like over i
was like probably over stoked where it
was like i feel like everyone was like
annoyed with how like excited i was that
i didn't die
and then i was like dude i [ __ ] up i
was too excited about this but then um
then later on i was just like hanging
around and like every it just hurt
really bad
and you couldn't breathe i couldn't
really was there did you go to the
doctor no no i didn't do that no i i
didn't go i think that's what got him
the part it's not so much the stunt it's
how he reacted after the stunt that's
what i think for you the fact that you
just say yeah and you don't know what
they're asking you to do you're like
yeah you had no trepidation about
putting your tongue into a taser
um
no not really because i can handle pain
i just and i knew i wasn't going to die
yeah so that seems to be an overall
theme for both of you like as long as
you don't die you're okay with anything
i mean i
that's that's probably death is probably
the scariest thing
you know to be afraid of so
i was just putting a lot of trust in
into that into the director and
yeah that they had my back but now
now how do you say no to your boyfriend
at all for anything
i'm not sure i do
oh i don't want to do that you put your
tongue in a taser i know you're not
going to die
and there was a director that told her
how to do it
was there was a stunt coordinator and
how do you know that you weren't going
to have like a heart attack that's a lot
of uh that's a shock i guess i didn't
know the science all behind it um
but yeah jeff just said lick it and i
was like okay
and you knew he was talking about the
taser yes specifically well i asked you
know if cops did it that way nobody
would get arrested you're right
[Laughter]
how long how many different stunts did
you do in the movie zack um i think it's
like
i think there's about sev like probably
eight or nine different things um
there's probably about there's usually
only like 20 something bits in a jackass
movie
um but i'm in about like like
anywhere from like seven to like nine
things but then there's also like a
bunch of other stuff that ends up being
uh
you know probably end up being in
whatever point five they make you know i
was watching i was watching the trailer
and you were really featured what is
your question i was gonna say is the
goal to get a whole bunch of new younger
cast members so like eventually when the
older cast members die don't want to die
don't want to do it anymore the
franchise continues is that the goal um
i don't i don't know i've never actually
i've never heard anyone say that
um i think it was just uh yeah i'm not
really sure i'm really not sure you
don't know what you're doing you're just
happy yeah i just like i'm this is like
a dream for me just to even be able to
work with these people like i i've been
i've looked up to them ever since i was
a kid and i love everything that they've
ever made how does your family feel
about this um they're
they're you know they're happy that i'm
you know following my dreams and that i
never didn't die yeah and i haven't died
yet
uh they're you know they're excited
about that
[Music]
bye